If your life were a book and you were the author, how would you want your story to go?
That's the question that changed my life, forever.
Growing up in a hot Las Vegas desert, all I wanted was to be free.
I would daydream about travelling the world living in a place where it snowed,...
...and I would picture all of the stories that I would go on to tell.
At the age of 19,  the day after I graduated highschool, I moved to a place where it snowed.
And I became a massage therapist.
With this job, all I needed were my hands and my massage table by my side and I could go anywhere.
For the first time in my life I felt free, independent and completely in control of my life.
That is, until my life took a detour.
I went home from work early one day with what I thought was the flu.
And less than 24 hours later I was in the hospital,...
...on life support with less than a two percent chance of living.
It wasn't until days later,...
...as I lay in a coma, that the doctors diagnosed me with bacterial meningitis.
A vaccine preventable blood infection.
Over the course of two and a half months, I lost my spleen, my kidneys,...
...the hearing in my left ear and both of my legs below the knee.
When my parents wheeled me out of the hospital I felt like I have been pieced back together...
...like a patchwork doll. I thought the worst was over,...
...until weeks later when I saw my new legs for the first time.
The calves were bulky blocks of metal with pipes bolted together for the ankles.
And a yellow rubber foot with the raised rubber line from the toe to the ankle to look like a vein.
I didn't know what to expect but I wasn't expecting that.
With my mom by my side and tears streaming down our faces...
...I strapped on this chunky legs and I stood up.
They were so painful and so confining that all I can think was,...
..."How am I ever going to travel the world on these things?"
"How was I ever going to live the life full of adventure and stories as I always wanted?"
And how was I going to snowboard again?